always stretched to the limit america's
education system now in crisis as the
latest covet outbreak and renegade
teachers unions wreak havoc schools
struggling to stay open some going
remote it's a stress mess that has
teachers and students on the brink in
fact the new survey finds over the last
month 48 of teachers admitting that they
have considered quitting the profession
that comes as the standoff in chicago
enters its third straight day lives
hanging in the balance for more than 300
thousand public school students out of
class some hungry some unsupervised and
yet the militant teachers union finding
some support from the ladies of the view
the notion that you know teachers should
just suck it up and go to work i i just
i think it's ridiculous they are
understaffed um it's unsafe they're
under tested there's no tests at home
this is a petri dish that they're being
told to walk into every day if we want
to make this less political it should be
the school superintendent taking the
lead on this not the politically elected
mayor of chicago
all right jesse there's a guy named
jessie sharkey who's a socialist who
runs the teachers union
so isn't chicago unique in the fact that
it has this militant teachers union that
really
goes way over what it seems in terms of
what's reasonable and what's not yeah
millet and it's a good word to describe
it geraldo this would be my plan to save
chicago i'd call oprah i'd say miss
winfrey this is your city go put out a
psa
let's get some fire lit under these
teachers and that would do a lot of good
she's got juice you know that then you
call michelle obama can you do something
michelle make a call michelle made a
call when jessie smilet got booked she's
not gonna get a call when 350 000 school
age students or being denied at
education i mean the chicago
schools got everything they wanted they
got nearly three billion dollars all the
teachers got to jump the line with the
vaccines
and now they're not even agreeing to a
deal they made with other democrats
democrats and democrats can't do a deal
it's no wonder republicans don't want to
deal with these people they won't even
give their own party a fair shake
imagine being a chicago parent
like you're you work at a butcher shop
you take a subway you go into an office
building you have adults breathing on
you all day
they're still going to work
but teachers can't go to work in one of
the safest environments there is a
classroom so i would do this i would
threaten the chicago teachers with a
test and not a coveted test an actual
test to see if they can actually teach
to see if they're qualified enough to
teach the students because basic reading
writing and arithmetic i'd even throw in
some questions about covid just to see
if they are knowledgeable at all about
this virus and if they can't get what
over 80 percent you dock their pay you
had a great idea geraldo if they get
over 80
you negotiate in good faith but i don't
think these teachers are even smart
enough to be in the classroom
degan jesse mentions test
you know one of the proposals by the
teachers union is that kids get tested
every kid gets tested before they open
the school and the kids can get tested
in the opinion of the union without the
consent of the parents how do you feel
about that they're vaccinated they're
basically refusing these teachers to go
to work for what is a bad cold where
they want to stay home and go to bars
and drink
get to work i wish lori lightfoot would
stand up and fire them all 73 percent of
these teachers voted to return to remote
learning if she fired them all and
pulled a ronald reagan wouldn't that be
something i guarantee you more than 27
of them would show up back in the
classroom those women on the view leave
it to selfish narcissists to defend
selfish narcissists
these uh these teachers are willing to
hurt children to protect themselves and
i just will point to all of the people
who sacrificed and did put their health
at risk way before a vaccine to just put
food on people's tables not just the
health care workers but the amazon
delivery people anybody delivering
groceries and packages putting it out
there even driving ubers putting it out
there every day these teachers
what half of them have thought about
quitting good we need to blow up the
whole system quit go find a job that
when you don't show up for work they
will fire your ass
greg it is like the squad is running uh
the the union isn't it yeah and you have
the view defending these teachers
because if the teachers go back to work
there goes the views audience right
these these teachers are the views key
demographic you know sluggish cat ladies
in sweat stained with chocolate eclairs
uh that's an image i woke up i've got it
but you know what that is kind of unfair
but it it but it illustrates unfair it
illustrates
navarro
let me get to my point geraldo this is
i'm making this point for a reason cat
temp made made
this point last night teachers unions
have managed to take one of the most
beloved occupations and redefined it as
selfish and lazy everyone we all of us
in our generations used to love our
teachers my mother was a teacher i bet
some of your mothers were teachers too
yeah and the system and the unions
destroyed the image of the teacher
turned the classroom into a supervised
prison so now this is one crisis where
that america shouldn't let go to waste
we should fire people it's time to pull
the money out of the system start
backing the parents give them the money
so they can make the choices of the best
education whether it's school choice
home schooling the peloton model that's
the only way you're going to make this
better is by introducing competition but
the unions hate the competition because
that means they got to take off the
jammies put on the clothes and go to
work
right but what about the point martha
what what about the point the point that
they want the kids all to be tested uh
and there are no tests available i mean
don't they have a point there martha
it's ridiculous i mean they got billions
of dollars to make sure that the schools
were safe they've been told they have to
go to work i and i agree what other
profession are you told you have to show
up for your job and if you don't show up
you don't get fired i mean it's
ridiculous and lori lightfoot wants to
not pay them good don't pay them if you
don't if you choose not to show up for
your job you shouldn't get paid and what
i find really encouraging here is that
there have been some teachers who have
bucked the trend bucked the union and
they said i'm showing up anyway um this
wonderful teacher who was on fox earlier
today who is in himself being treated
for cancer he said these children are my
priority that is why people go into
teaching that's why my mother went into
teaching my sister is an amazing teacher
but that's why they teach because they
love the children and they want to be
there and you're right these individuals
have completely changed people's idea of
teaching and people need more agency and
that's why they're taking it seven
percent drop in enrollment in the
chicago public school system in the last
three years people are voting with their
feet and in places like arizona and west
virginia and florida you can take your
dollars and you can spend them the way
you want they spend way too much money
in the chicago public school system on
each child it's obviously not working
because you can spend a lot less in
catholic schools and other schools
charter schools and get a lot more for
your money hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else